aren't you curious why red dead
redemption one of the most requested
backwards compatible games for xbox one
isn't available yet Microsoft has spoken
out to explain why red dead redemption
among other popular xbox 360 games isn't
playable and Xbox one through backwards
compatibility at least not yet as you
might have guessed it's likely it has
something to do with licensing
agreements Microsoft engineer Richard
Irving told Eurogamer after the
technological breakthrough that got
backwards compatibility working the next
step was to figure out how to license
all this content originally released on
the 360 for Xbox one he added that
ultimately its publishers who decide if
they want to improve their 360 titles to
be playable on Xbox one this
back-and-forth takes time Irving stress
which is why Microsoft was not able to
deliver all of the top 50 to 100 most
requested games pressed about red dead
redemption specifically which is
published by Rockstar Games Irving said
we're definitely engaged with all of our
publisher and developer partners
including rockstar Rockstar Games is one
of the only major publishers that has no
presence in the initial list of 104
backwards compatible games hope is not
lost however Microsoft plans to deliver
hundreds more in the future though a
specific lineup of upcoming games has
not yet been announced a backwards
compatible version of red dead
redemption sounds great but come on what
we really want is the sequel